Okay.
All right.
What the hell address the Jewish question?
That's a hell of a thing to ask.
So that's Jacqueline turn,
you know,
I mean really that's a
hell of a thing to ask,
but I will say something about it.
You know,
and I've thought about this a lot.
So there is evidence that Ashkenazi Jews,
so those are Jews of European heritage,
have iqs that are about 15 points
higher than the population average.
So that's a lot 15 points.
It's about the average difference between
the typical high school student and
the typical state college student.
It's a lot.
And one of the things that means is,
so imagine there's two distributions and
that they overlap and that the Jewish
one is,
uh,
is the mean is as one 15 so the whole
distribution has shifted to the right.
What that means is if you go up into the
Higher Iq strata one 31 45 way the hell
up there,
that Jewish people are overwhelmingly
overrepresented at the high end of the
Eicu distribution.
Now the price they pay for that is some
increased propensity for neurological
diseases.
That seems to be associated in
some sense with that heightened Iq.
Now,
you know,
the science on this isn't settled but,
but it,
it's reasonably solid.
It,
it'll given the standards of such things.
Okay,
so Jews are going to be over represented
at the high end of cognitively complex
disciplines.
So then I would say,
and that's the case,
like they're way overrepresented among
like outstanding scientists and among
Nobel prize winners and so forth.
And so you know,
people look and they think,
well why are there a disproportionate
number of Jewish people in positions of
authority?
And they say,
well,
it must be a conspiracy.
You know,
it must be systemic in some sense.
It's like,
no,
it can be simply accounted for by
that relatively large Iq differential.
Now the next criticism would be,
well,
don't the Jews tend to lean left?
Well first you might say,
well,
you know,
given what happened in Nazi Germany to
the degree that that was right wing as we
discussed earlier,
that's the nationalism and ethnocentrism.
It's hardly surprising that they might,
you know,
in this historical period of time
tend to move towards the left.
But more importantly than that,
I queue is associated with trait
openness and trade openness is a strong
predictor predictor of
political liberalism.
So,
and it's the strongest predictor
of political liberalism.
So you know,
it's very difficult.
So that's what I have to say about that.
It's like,
and the other thing I would say is,
you know,
the fact that there's a population is
subpopulation of people who are much
smarter than average,
not on average,
right?
On average,
I've got to get that straight on average
is actually of great benefit to the
rest of us because what do you want?
Fewer geniuses,
fewer people with Iqs
of 145 or 160 that's,
and you know,
and it's no conspiracy that
people who are smarter,
higher up in competence hierarchies
because accused the best predictor of
movement up in a complex
car competence hierarchy.
So there,
I've addressed the Jewish question.
It's like it's a confusion
between ethnicity and and
Iq as far as I'm concerned.
So I'll probably get like painted six
different shades of black for that answer.
But it's,
I've thought about a long time.
It's the best that I can manage.